si on propose plus belle chambrée genre
un peu suite un peu un peu sympa à tous
c'est qu'il ya un piège bien c'est
encore une une ânerie ça voilà je me
méfie beaucoup je suis totalement
paranoïaque ici ça va la chambre de la
cedh pour la soie que personne n'a fait
que d'une blague
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on va bientôt le savoir battre ça mais
j'ai très mal de séjour parce qu'elle
était vraiment en colère vous la
connaissez la belgique au débotté des
menaces je fus le bordel sur les réseaux
et leur benjamin castaldi
ils devaient dormir avec delphine
wespiser s'était filmé wespiser est
arrivé après sirène
il devait donc couché dans la même
chambre il admire et lui est un gros
coup de pression de sa femme regarde
c'est le moins que l'on puisse dire
durant la chambre n'est pas gros c'est
moi qui choisis mais je reviens moi même
donc ça me ferais tu vas petit va
dégager tout ça s'amuse à faire froid
oui ça ben non je te montent parce que
le gars calme lui se veut montrer que
d'autres que la douche c'est ce qui est
allé dit voilà bah ouais voilà bienvenus
non ma chance at appris le tas pris le
meilleur lien non j'ai prélevé le lien
côté du chauffage
non mais je les fais jamais de chantage
c'était la fontaine de jouvence ou quoi
ça vient on fait un peu nerveux attend 1
aller 2 3 des gaz de machin virez moi
miss monde de ma chambre je ne veux pas
de cette meuf dans ma chambre c'est
clair français en dessous jeunes c'est
des bons de patrouille l'a dit nous
sommes avec toi mais tu attends musée du
léman 10 secondes de ma chambre avec dis
très clairement je ne suis jamais fait
refouler comme ça je pense que je suis
tombé sur le moins sympa de la bande qui
passent une nuit qui n'y seront vendors
dans sa chambre mais tous âges mais non
mais pas moi je suis pas chanceux je
suis marié je suis marié voilà bah
comprend pas elle pas je veux pas dormir
avec une femme que ma femme dans une
jambe avec qui tu es mais pas avec moi
tout seul tu t'en avec ta sorte la merde
tu dégages de massa sera jamais tu
dégages de ma chambre est donné en
laponie maintenant mais moi c'était
juste pour faire connaissance
je suis la petite nouvelle donc je
m'attendais à un accueil un peu plus
chaleureux non mais tout ça parce tu
veux pas dormir avec moi donc c'est un
incroyable changé parce qu'on regarde et
vois là et tu sais j'ai très bien elle
voilà voilà rien plein de place à aller
c'est trop claque là c'est pas ma
carrière au plat à bavois la doré ses
patrons il est bien là bas les miettes à
chambre alors malgré le grand lit les
pétales de fleurs et tout volé j'ai pris
une décision mais j'aimerais continuer à
dormir avec benjamin je me le suis parce
qu'avec lui non non t'inquiète pas il
signe dans les règlements n'ont pas il
se présente non je vous l'apprends la
difficulté je dors avec elle si je
prends une lettre à battre hachoud es
parti
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
produire sur le fait que vous avez des
pétales de roses c'est vous dire
pourquoi parce qu'au départ ça devait
être la love room
et comme je l'avais pas de chambre j'ai
dû aller dans cette chambre et j'avais
je vous le dis toute la nuit parce que
je dors un petit peu de tenue j'avais
des pétales de rose partout sont
différentes à la totale voilà je vous le
dis bon et voyez ma chambre et déjà
bordélique au bout de quelques jours
vous avez absolument vous voulez dormir
avec benjamin castaldi mais bon on a dit
négocier de manière incroyable mais
petit à petit c'est ici à sagy 1 par la
suite le groupe double foyer bien sûr
bien sûr aussi à 22 ans vous avez dormi
ensemble oui non comment ça c'est pas la
peine de mort est puni mais bon allez on
dit que je suis cru dans la bonne humeur
dans la maison et je m'endormis ensemble
mais séparément la question des prix
tout a choisi ge et benjamin insisté je
suis pas à nice et cyril qui l'a qui a
dit donc ce que cyril dit on a plus
la dictature personnelle on en bave
projet bien sûr
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
les ottomans alors vous étiez contente
de dormir avec lui mais elle n'a pas
dormi avec moi il suffit de regarder la
télé il faut arrêter voilà ta vie tu
vous voulez je vous héberge quelques
jours elle a aucun problème et non mais
derrière le ronflement ça allait les
chéris je trouvais par des passes ils
iront que c'était bien lui alors les
chéris on est parti pour aller voir le
père noël puisque on est parti pour les
premiers rangs de la berd chez moi ou
des matchs et moi oui mais on va tout de
suite partir en randonnée pour aller
trouver le père noël ça la faisait
briller en sélection n'est pas l'évacuer
pas pousser la rendre belle partie